lamy
clairement l'un des plus grands
problèmes dans les débats c'est les égos
et c'est pas forcément un truc très
négatif s'est passé juste on a tous des
ego et puis surtout on a tous envie de
ne pas perdre la face en public naturel
impressionnant de risquer d'être
discréditer complètement sur tous les
aspects s'ils s'y montre qu'on a tort et
du coup on a tendance à vouloir se
défendre et bien sûr tout ça c'est une
motivation énorme bullshit et à être de
mauvaise foi et surtout ne pas faire
preuve d'honnêteté intellectuelle
mais ce qui est vrai de nous dans le
débat est aussi vrai des autres et du
coup si on veut amener les gens à mieux
réfléchir à ne pas bullshit et à ne pas
être de mauvaise foi et à puce réfléchir
en fait ce qui est vraiment utile c'est
d'installer une sécurité sociale quand
on en a déjà parlé et en particulier
quand l'autre sens qu'il ya un risque de
perdre la face si jamais ils acceptent
qui s'est trompé à ce moment là plutôt
que le forcer à dire qu'il s'est trompé
ce qui risque d'augmenter son envie en
fait de deux être de mauvaise foi
à ce moment là il est utile de d'offrir
ce que je vais appeler un parachute doré
donc en fait l'expression vient du livre
arabe une possible condamnation ou
l'auteur ou les auteurs parlent de
golden bridge comme quelqu'un d'un pont
doré mais l'idée est la même mais j'aime
bien l'idée de parachute doré
parce que c'est un type qui existent
également d'entreprises va quand
quelqu'un se fait virer d'une entreprise
surtout si c'est quelqu'un d'important
un pdg ou autres pour lui éviter de
perdre complètement la face ou pour
faire en sorte que ça il s'agirait qui
lui allait pas crier sur tous les toits
qu'ils ont entreprises et a été horrible
avec lui on lui offre un parachute doré
et puis là comme ça il part il peut
peut-être même dire du bien d'entreprise
en partant vivait là est la même c'est
que au moment d'un débat surtout si vous
sentez que vous avez une certaine
manière déjà convaincu l'autre déjà
gagné je mets des gros guillemets soit
gagner le débat
si vous vous sentez que vous avez
atteint votre objectif de le faire
réfléchir et que la personne est en
train de réfléchir c
là le bon moment pour lui offrir un
parachute doré pour lui dire bon basique
ou en gros lot continuer à l'encourager
de réfléchir mais en lui disant qu'il
n'a pas perdu du tout la face et même en
faisant comprendre à tous les auditeurs
que yahia rails là il n'a pas perdu du
tout il a peut-être que vous avez gagné
mais l'autre à peu perdu ça s'est un peu
l'idéal tout le monde a gagné c'est un
peu l'idéal c'est un peu utopique est
malheureusement bien souvent quand tu
tombes des baumes on a envie de marquer
le coup on envie de dire j'ai gagné
parce que l'autre a perdu alors que
n'est pas obligé quoi on n'est pas
obligé d'être aussi trouvé mon fils fa
liste et finalement si notre objectif en
tout cas est de convaincre ou de
personnes ou de faire réfléchir
bah c'est cette envie de monter à
l'autre qu'il a perdu et en fait
extrêmement contre-productive
il vaut mieux essayer de montrer à
l'autre qu'il a gagné qui il a gagné
parce qu'il va maintenant mieux
réfléchir que ça va lui ouvrir d'autres
perspectives que ça va le stimuler
intellectuellement quelque chose comme
ça et ça ça correspond vraiment à les
offrir un parachute doré donc ya pas mal
d'exemples problèmes potentiels de
parachute doré
je pense est sujette amplement à se dire
il a fait ce qu'on veut on parle d'un
truc sympa voilà on peut passer à autre
chose un autre type de parachute doré
consiste à insister sur une erreur qu'on
a fait nous une erreur similaire peut
par exemple mais vraiment insister sur
l'erreur de nous ils pas l'erreur tafer
l'autre ou encore un autre type
parachutes dorés consiste à revenir sur
un truc génial qui a dit l'autre pour
qu'il se sente bien et qu'on est inutile
et vraiment l'impression qu'il est
quelque chose de très positif qui est
sorti de la discussion
c'est ça aussi ça permet d'encourager
d'autres discussions et d'autres
réflexions à venir
et tout ça me semble vraiment être de
très bonnes idées pour amener les gens à
mieux réfléchir à mieux se questionner
et à éviter de bouchité et en
particulier de s'auto bullshit et